joining us now is the former
conservative party leader in Duncan
Smith thank you so much for being on the
program
um I'm very keen to talk to you about
China but just first we've just heard
from the German ambassador and I was
quite interested in what he said on
brexit he said that he was quite
optimistic that there would be a change
in tone on the talks on Northern Ireland
that there will be a closer relationship
between the EU and the UK and what's
your sort of sense of where Rishi senek
is when it comes to president well I
think the truth is it's not really where
Rishi sunak is I think because I think
he would love to have a good engagement
I think there's a big question mark for
what the European Union wants to do
because in the protocol it's quite clear
that two things one Good Friday
agreement trumps everything else and at
the moment we have a problem because
consent doesn't take place in Northern
Ireland so which is why the unions have
walked away from the assembly and the
second thing is very important article
13.8 make it absolutely clear if there
are any problems with the protocol the
protocol can be changed in whole or in
part right right now Mr ceskovich does
not have the power to negotiate on 13.8
which is critical because it's not
working so what we're doing at the
moment is still a slight kind of
elaborate dance around this at the heart
of this is article 13.8 I know it sounds
technical but it says the protocol can
be changed in whole or in part it's not
working we should be discussing that and
both sides reach an agreement which
allows them to respect each other's
Market requirements I think that's the
key okay interesting but how slightly
further away than a previous one maybe
not yeah um okay and now you are one of
the most outspoken critics of China
you've previously been sanctioned by
them for speaking out about the uyghurs
so I'm interested to know your thoughts
on the you know the extraordinary scenes
we've seen recently are people taken to
the streets to protest uh initially of
course about the anti-lockdown rules of
the sort of lockdown rules um do you
think change could be happening in China
I I we the trouble is I think with all
of us in the west is that we're
basically all decent people who believe
in democracy Freedom human rights all
the rest of it whether you're in Germany
or in France or in Britain or wherever
on America our tendency is we always
want to believe that the good is coming
and that somehow the natural order of
things is democracy human rights and the
rule of law but with China I think we
have to have a reality check this is a
brutal dictatorial government that
thinks nothing of incarcerating people
it's carrying out genocide amongst the
uyghur in xinjiang I mean literally
slave labor products we buy have got
slave labor in them here all around the
Western World we've done very little to
stop that so this is a a government that
thinks nothing of cracking down so their
control is total they use technology in
a way that we just couldn't imagine over
here all of that tells me that they're
not going anywhere soon they are
determined that their former government
is right and they will not let up so
once they won't modify around the edges
because the covert issues causing them
economic problems as well I don't think
we should overread this at all president
XI is absolutely determined that the
form of government China has is the
formal government for everywhere and
he's selling it to the uh the developing
world right now you're very strong in
your condemnation of what you see it's a
brutal regime what ship of the UK
government response how should we go
about our relationship well I'm deeply
disappointed in my government over this
particular area because of course you
know president the Prime Minister said
during the summer that he thought that
China represented a systemic threat and
then recently he shifted that to
systemic challenge the problem with
challenges it looks weak and we've now
got a policy which it sounds like it
could have come from Sir Humphrey in Yes
Minister which is robust pragmatism now
if somebody can please tell me what
robust pragmatism means it means nothing
robust but also pragmatic they cancel
each other out the reality we've got to
do is we've got to change our integrated
review to put China in as a systemic
threat the Americans are way ahead of us
on this other countries in Europe are
talking about it we the UK could risk
being left behind dragging our feet it
from that everything flows from that
about how we relate to China what does
that mean in Practical terms I mean I
know you've talked a bit about smart
meters for example before are there any
kind of concrete examples of what
acknowledging or saying that China is a
systematic threat would mean being a
systemic threat then going into the
integrated route as a threat as Russia
was means that everything that the
government does then flows from that
point so it means that you can no longer
be ambivalent about what China does you
have to view it in the light of it being
a threat so that means for example we've
got illegal I think they're illegal but
the government seems to turn a blind eye
to them Chinese police stations bullying
Chinese expats to go back they're not
alone in this they're in all sorts of
countries Holland the Netherlands
Germany all these countries but they're
being much more aggressive about it the
Holland has shut down uh theirs the
other day America's kicking them out yet
we seem to be completely ambivalent
about whether or not they're doing this
bullying having video links back to
Beijing with their families brought in
being threatened in front of them if
they don't go back we've got this new
Embassy complex that they want to build
with you the biggest Embassy complex in
the whole of Europe right in the heart
of Europe right next door to the city of
London you know really astonishingly
inept if the government now allows the
appeal to go through we can go on all
these things Confucius Institute spying
on Chinese students our University is
completely dependent on Chinese money
and us as an economy far too dependent
on China a digital regime none of this
can happen unless we see them as a
threat that's the key the pragmatism is
the economic reality of it right that's
how some would see it at a time when you
know we'll look spiral cancer we are in
a recession do we not need to have that
trade relationship with China for the
good of the economy well it depends what
your trade-off is I think this is a
trade-off in human lives
for me the uyghur being
incarcerated the women sterilized
forcibly sterilized often raped we've
got children in re-education camps we've
got uh just a ton of men in forced labor
camps thousands of miles away from their
family never seeing their family again
that's just one bit of it you've got
Tibet forced labor camps you've got the
Christian churches the Evangelical
Church has been cracked down on arrests
taking place Hong Kong you know people
being arrested for their peaceful
democracy campaigns I mean where do you
draw the line do we turn a blind eye to
all of that and say we just go on making
money out of China my answer is
diversify bring some of these
Technologies back to to Europe to the
continent of Europe to Britain to
America actually start looking at India
and others to invest more in to develop
them as a counterbalance can't go on
turning a blind eye to the fact that our
cheaper products come from countries
that use slave labor not on um I just
want to talk to you a little bit as if
at the end about the state of the
conservative party and polling's still
looking pretty difficult to say the
least are you obviously lost the Chester
by-election that itself wasn't a
surprise but labor achieved their
greatest result there for 200 years
um Nadim zahari said that looking at the
pulse he thinks kirst armor should be
worried do you think that's right well
interestingly uh John Curtis the day
after said that whilst this would give
labor this result probably a majority he
didn't say a massive majority he was his
point was making that you'd have
expected them to do better I'm not now
going to be clever about this but the
truth is if you're an opposition you
should be winning a by-election like
that midterm with all our problems right
now by a massive degree and it wasn't as
big now having said that we lost it so
the conservatives shouldn't go around
telling themselves all is okay because
it's going to come right in here it's
like you're
there's about 1200 I think yeah you
could be in trouble yeah well I've been
told I'm in trouble for the last three
elections but I've managed to get back
um all I would say is that conservative
should be complacent we have to get this
economy growing at the heart of this
life people fears about two things I
think one is obviously about migration
the boat's crossing the channel which is
headline stuff and really worrying
people the second bit importantly though
is growth all the economies of Europe
facing very much the same struggle but
the UK has got now the highest tax rate
that it's had for a generation and we've
got to get that down so we need growth
back in the economy easily by next
spring so that we can start to put these
things right and people can feel better
off with access to jobs and to good
incomes these are the key things that
will win us through at the end not
tokenistic excuses about the fact it
could have been better for labor than it
was
um you of course know what it's like to
lead the conservative party in the
depths of opposition do you think you
might be heading back into that
Wilderness all political parties in
government face the prospect of losing
the next election because elections are
about your record often more than they
are about the alternative so the key
question for us is to get the choice
much more difficult for the public
otherwise we would end up going into
opposition and that means making them
make a choice and if we have growth if
we have an economy going forward if you
have people getting jobs livelihoods
looking better people were able to pay
their mortgages and we get that
migration issue under control then we're
in at the races and we have a chance of
winning back into government okay it
sounds like a tough Challenge and thank
you very much for being on the program
and speaking I say strongly about China
as well thank you